what hey youtubers this is going to be
my episode 4 video we can finally talk
about it freely just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
we're officially halfway through the
season so if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a new round of the
HBO now giveaway - I'll still be doing
that for the rest of the year but there
were so many big reveals in this episode
even though it was the shortest of the
season so let's do top 10 WTF and book
references starting with number 10 we
finally get a solid bran scene
I'm so happy Jerome Flynn is back he's
one of the best actors on the show so
just like Diana Rigg Queen of thorns
they expanded that part just because
he's so fantastic but you can kind of
tell how he's a little bit of Jaime's
conscience but he's also reminding you
that he knows exactly who he is he's
kind of a hound type character where yet
he recognizes that he does a lot of bad
things but he's coming to the point
where he's starting to question the
morality of it all
like when Jaime asked him to go use his
talents to get the grain from all the
farmers of the reach and they thread in
this really cool idea of the more you
have the more troubles you have the more
ways you down making you wonder if maybe
Jaime will not be quite so way down by
the end of the season how much longer is
it going to be before he takes that
Cersei chain from around his neck and
throws it on the ground and by the end
of the episode bran sort of sees his
gold sack lying there
leaves it so it implies that he's going
to be much more free for the rest of the
season to less burden by some of the
more terrible things that they've been
doing the last couple of episodes
another well time Rick and joke
triggering everybody again Rickon no
[ __ ] so Jaime is like slowly showing
his true colors like he'll come around
eventually he just doesn't quite got to
that point yet but number 9 the iron
bank is so happy that they're getting
their money back but terrified at the
idea that they'll lose the business of
the crowd this is one of those really
funny sinister moments where Cersei is
like yes I'm getting everything that I
want my plan is clear and Ty CONUS
Taurus is sort of like keeping up over
the
s-say hey is there anything else that we
can help you with maybe there's another
giant loan that you need I don't
remember what the exact debt of the
crown is but it was several million
crowns I believe like it's just meant to
be this astronomical figure that you
could barely fathom literally everything
they have used to repay this debt
overnight so they're just like this is
amazing but please let us give you
another loan so we can start collecting
on that one too we love making money off
of you guys as great as that is the
really big thing here though is the name
drop of the golden company so if you're
not a book reader the golden company was
actually formed by black buyers after
the Blackfyre rebellion daemon Blackfyre
the last known possessor of the blade
black fire that belonged to Aegon
Targaryen which rightfully belongs to
Daenerys now was driven into exile after
the first Blackfyre rebellion he passed
that along to his descendants the sword
ended up being lost but the golden
company became this amazing mercenary
company they would just relentlessly
pursue their target they have a golden
reputation for delivering on their
contracts so the iron bank says oh yes
we use them to collect on delinquent
loans Cersei implies that they're going
to be hiring them to bolster their
forces and now it sounds like they
definitely need them because of all the
troops that Daenerys killed no idea
they'll include Jon connington
or if they'll include any Aegon
references they might wink at that but
because they've been rushing the story
forward so quickly I think they're
mostly focusing on the Jon Snow
Targaryen reveal so I don't think we're
going to see any surprise alternate
Targaryen popping up but number 8 chaos
is a ladder brand knows everything so we
talked about this in previous videos
what are brand's powers what does he
know does he secretly peep on everybody
in Westeros so the way the brand
explains it is that he knows everything
that's happened but the problem is is
that he can't focus on it and he's so
inhuman now that it's really hard to
communicate with them effectively but
within that same breadth Littlefinger
gives him the cat's paws the Valyrian
dagger that was used to try and kill him
during season 1 and it seems like he's
just trying to butter him up like he
thinks that he's going to become the new
Lord of Winterfell so I better get in
good with him I'd better start working
my claws into him the way I'm working
them into Sansa but if they haven't been
clear buff
for this episode definitely wanted to
let you know that the star children are
starting to become a Wolfpack and
Littlefinger is the lone wolf now so
lone wolf dies pack survives the
important thing to remember though is
that even though brand knows everything
that Littlefinger's done his role in Ned
Stark's death before anybody could
revenge kill Littlefinger they would
have to prove his treachery to the other
lords of the Vale
so they would continue to back Sansa in
House Stark
even without Littlefinger around his
role in John Aaron's death would be a
really solid way to do that John Royce
there would probably strangle
Littlefinger himself if he found out
that Littlefinger had a big role in
killing Jon Arryn so depending on what
happens we can revisit that stuff but
it's all callbacks to season one this
season they reference a lot of Arya
stuff from Season one in the episode so
when it comes to Littlefinger's downfall
it'll probably have something to do with
what he did preceding or during season
one but loved that brand meera scene he
is such a dick you died in that cave
they just want to make him seem like
he's gone full-blown dr. Manhattan he's
lost his humanity
so Mira is out of there we're probably
not going to hear from her for the rest
of the season we might not even see her
during season eight maybe when she gets
home she could tell Howland Reed to come
show up and tell everybody about Jon
Snow but number seven Arya returns to
Winterfell so this is a very touching
moment if you didn't recognize that song
cue that they used as she was looking on
the horizon there that's called winter
has come that's literally the name of
the song anytime there's a big stark
scene you hear it in the background so
it's kind of a stark theme
winter is coming is their motto so
winter like Arya has come home just like
winter has come but all the funny
moments with the guards as well as my
number six the fight with Brienne are
just intended to show you what her ninja
skills are like what she might look like
when she's going after somebody so they
just want to make her seem like this
really badass character but I felt like
the fight was actually pretty good one
of the best Arya fights we've ever seen
there's a lot of the Bravo stuff that
just didn't quite work for me as much
but if you really want to get down to it
like if you really analyze their fight
she would have zero chances against
Brienne the realest moment of this fight
was when Brienne kicked her across the
courtyard like a sack of potatoes she
would crush Arya no matter how
she was but you have to imagine that
there's a certain magical component
Arya's abilities so that could explain
why someone her size could take on
someone Bri inside and there were so
many references to Syrio Forel in her
technique here most of her training came
from the house of black and white
so when Brienne asks her who taught you
how to fight like that and she says no
one it's a bit of a wink at the house of
black and white but she's holding her
blade like Syrio Forel and the Braavosi
water dancers so they just want to let
you know that she still remembers all
the things that Serio taught her as well
as what she learned in the house of
black and white
so obviously the other side of this too
is the callback to Littlefinger watching
this all play out and just taking it all
in so a fun part of this episode was
just seeing how Littlefinger reacted to
all the supernatural stark children like
oh oh you know everything that I've done
okay I'm going to crap my pants now I'll
be back later and then as surprised as
he is by Arya's actual abilities he also
notices that she has the dagger that he
just gave to brand making it pretty
clear to him how brand feels about the
situation like I don't care about this
dagger I don't care about you and I know
everything that you've done
so Littlefinger just being backed into a
corner slowly but number five stark
reunion so there were a couple reunions
you have Orion Santa and the crypts then
you have their reunion with brand so
these could have been the worst moment
of the episode and I feel like this
Winterfell plot relies on their
chemistry together
so if their scenes didn't work you'd be
forced to sit through a couple more
hours of them together for the rest of
the season so it could have been really
bad if it didn't work out but I think
that Maisie and sophie Turner did a
pretty good job with their scenes they
do a good job through their performances
of letting you know what their
relationship has been they've never
gotten along they'd never seen
eye-to-eye they've always been so
different but now that they've been
through so much the idea is they come
together they form this Wolf Pack so I
wouldn't be surprised if Littlefinger
tries to use that to his advantage in
the next couple of episodes we'll see if
they actually end up doing that but let
me know in the comments how you think
that Littlefinger is going to try and
play his hand now they all the stark
children seem like they're coming
together but Ari and Sansa still aren't
super crazy about each other
remember chaos is a ladder so he's going
to find some way to create more chaos
within the stark family but number four
back to Dragonstone Jonathan Ayers in
the cave this is actually a really great
scene they want to show you some of the
chemistry they have together and I do
think that from their scenes so far
they've shown that they have chemistry
on-screen together but right up until
the left turn that she makes it just
meant to show that they're slowly coming
around on each other Jon Snow's being as
genuine as possible I need your help
I don't think that I can do this without
you in that really important line from
Daenerys where she says I will fight for
you Jon Snow so a preview of things to
come but not before a bunch of other
drama happens between now and then like
they don't want to make it seem too easy
even though you know what the end point
is like obviously at some point she's
going to say that and mean it without
forcing him to bend the knee but the
important thing here is all these cave
drawings from the children of the forest
so obviously they're mostly used as an
exposition tool and you see that
circular symbol show up that the knight
King drew and that you saw when he was
being created so this symbol recurs alot
it'll probably come back a couple more
times as well so right now it just seems
like a reference to the cycle of Ice and
Fire like this is where it all began and
this is where it all comes back to they
offhandedly referenced the war with the
first men the pact that they signed on
the Isle of faces and John says a long
long time ago but in reality that was
between 8 and 10,000 years ago in the
book so you could say thousands of years
ago on the TV show but I did find myself
wondering what the children of the
forest were doing at Dragonstone if
there wasn't a weirwood there because
you don't see them popping up to many
places outside of the forest so maybe at
one point there were we're woods on
Dragonstone but of course she's off
number three we get our reunion with
Theon he washes up on the beach and Jon
Snow oh this is so great
so you haven't seen a moment with them
together since season 1 and he knows
everything that Theon has done he might
even still think the brain is dead
although I wonder if Sansa told him
everything that Theon did because he
says that's the only reason I'm not
killing you is because of what you did
for Santa but when Santa was rescued by
Fiat he told her that he didn't really
kill bran and Rickon so I'm still
betting on the idea that bran is dead
and he thinks that Arya is probably dead
too because she hasn't made any
reference to her these past seasons you
would think somebody from Winterfell
with
Ravin to Dragonstone oh by the way John
you're brother and sister that you
thought were dead have just turned up
but we got to start talking about the
last 15 minutes of the episode so good
Daenerys attacks Jaime's Caravan with
the Dothraki and drogon so poor tyrion
he just gets thrown under the bus here
enough your clever plans your plans are
[ __ ] I know it seems like Daenerys has
mad at him but she's just really pissed
off about how things have been going so
I don't think there's going to be any
really big problems between them within
Daenerys of small Council but before the
battle the really important thing here
is that she turns to John Snow and says
what the hell would you do in this
situation pretty much tells her that you
attack King's Landing and burn it to the
ground nobody's going to want to follow
you and because she attacked Jaime's
Caravan it means that she listened to
his advice so it's a really effective
way of showing you what their status is
right now she's still being really
stubborn about him bending the knee but
she is listening to his counsel she
recognizes him as a full-blown ally at
this point so the battle the first real
battle that we've gotten this season and
one of the best ones that the show has
done so far even though it's in one of
the shortest episodes you get to see
what the Dothraki are capable of and if
you don't remember it there's this
really amazing line that Robert
Baratheon had when he said only a fool
would meet the Dothraki in an open field
so even though you have the added effect
of drogon here burning all this
Lannister soldiers you still would have
had this thunderous sea of Dothraki
washing over them I love the way they
make them sound like the storm Daenerys
Stormborn it sounds like a storm is
approaching just as the Dothraki crests
the hill in the dragon swoops in through
the clouds so there's so much stuff
going on here so much exposition that
they get across as the battle starts as
well so just as a reminder randyll Tarly
rides up right before the Dothraki
attack and says the last of the gold has
made it through the gates at King's
Landing there were a lot of people that
saw the preview after last week's
episode and said well that gold is not
getting to Cersei she's not going to get
her army but because of randyll Tarly is
comment it means that Cersei did get the
gold and she will get those additional
troops
so when you see drogon just burning the
hell out of this Caravan here that's all
the grain that they collected from the
farmers of the reach so you see what
they did there they're balancing the
playing field so Daenerys
a bunch of her army she takes out a
bunch of the Lannister army if it wasn't
clear the people that she killed were
only a small fraction of the Lannister
army that you saw at Highgarden so like
all these other people there's thousands
of troops here this little piece of the
caravan that you're seeing is just like
a small little bit of that we watched
rogue on almost get winged he's down but
it hits him in his shoulder so like
Daenerys starts yanking it out
he'll probably be fine but number one
probably my favorite moment of the
episode though is Sir Jaime the Dragon
Slayer he was the King Slayer now he's
going to try and be the Dragon Slayer
unsuccessfully so you see him charging
drogon we have that great line from
Tyrion and what I actually think is
going on here is that he was trying to
kill Daenerys not drogon and if it
wasn't clear that's a bran snatching him
off the horse at the end so they're both
fine but they are at the mercy of
Daenerys his army now so we'll see what
ends up happening next is he going to be
their captive are they going to try and
parlay with King's Landing like we have
your Jaime maybe we can make a bargain
we'll give them back to you but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite moment from the episode what
will happen next is I'll do my trailer
video then I'll post new Rick and Morty
but if there are any bonus videos that
you guys want me to do based on stuff in
this episode just let me know in the
comments congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner joyful 33 please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything to post you can
click here to learn all about Jon Snow
and Dragons and you can click here for
my episode 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight